and now i'm crying over this man that i
didn't even really like like he's a
mediocre white man like the rest of them
and here i am crying about him but it's
not even about wait wait wait wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
this is for all my girlies who like me
have a god complex and an inferiority
complex why do i find it
so hard to shoot my shot
when i want somebody like baby i know
i know what i look like
i know that i'm bringing this to the
table
i debated
hosting this on my main account or not
because
because it's a little personal
but
you know i've been speaking a lot about
how
awful men treat
women
overall and i just had the shittiest
experience on top of like
truly 10 plus shitty experiences with
men
since i've been single and i had a guy
that i matched with that was putting in
all this effort
to make a date with me planning the time
the date the place
telling me all these things about him
and and how good of a catch he is and
this and that basically being what i
call a fuckboy in sheep's clothing and
because i don't think there's a problem
with sleeping with someone on the first
date we did but we also had like a nice
connection and we i thought we really
liked each other and then afterwards he
kind of ghosted kind of didn't he came
back with some saucy messages here and
there reactions to my stories to my you
know
pretty pictures of me and stuff and then
i finally to try to be like what the
hell is going on i said so when's our
next date when we gonna get together and
watch
survivor or something and he was like
whenever you want
like i'll i'll hop on a train and come
to you whenever you want and i said you
know your energy has really changed were
you only looking for something
casual possible
you know what
eric
shut the [ __ ] up
you know what
eric
this ain't your name that i will talk
that's his name
i'll shut up now
sorry what were you saying
that was a lot
undoubtedly some people mislead others
also maybe you weren't even misled maybe
he really was interested
then he had with you right you cleaned
the pipes
and
maybe this wasn't good maybe he just
didn't like you throughout the day when
someone's interests you initially it
doesn't mean that that's constantly
going to carry over and two dudes have
to understand that
what you're putting forth initially
understand you may be asking from them a
larger investment than what you're
actually willing to reciprocate right
based off how you're talking to them
it's like sometimes guys can sometimes
give off that impression to ladies based
off how they act how much they show an
interest like you also have to be
cognizant of how your your actions come
across as a man i've had this happen to
me before where i thought i was really
into someone and i could just tell you
man just after having sex once like i
was like oh hell no we can't do or maybe
show up on the date and you still go
through a really nice date with the girl
but she doesn't look nearly as good as
her pictures
okay or maybe you go on a date and you
realize this girl's annoying as [ __ ] but
you still show a good face and then
afterwards well why would he keep saying
nice things to me because it's sometimes
hard to tell someone you're annoying us
and i don't want to talk to you because
you actually think they're a good person
but you don't want to hurt their
feelings so there's a lot of things that
play that
people aren't willing to
sing directly that's what you're saying
they're actually thinking on the inside
because saying the truth may be too rude
yeah
you know yeah sometimes i think the
truth is people don't like confidence
and it took him six hours to reply
watched all my stories in the meantime
and said
i had a really great time with you but i
don't see this going anywhere seriously
honestly i wasn't looking for anything
outright yeah well you could have told
me that after you decided to sleep with
me again
after you decided that you
don't see this going anywhere serious i
don't know what has to get through men's
little [ __ ] pee brains
to understand that if you're outright
about it usually we're going to be chill
with it okay so
so this is where she loses right okay
because
you see a change in heart and you think
it's due to you playing uh
you're a boy or
you have some malicious intention
sometimes you just lose interest
sometimes the person you meet in person
isn't what you want that happens the
same way ladies you can come into a date
and say i'm ready i'm down to then you
start to have second thoughts and that
it's okay you're allowed to change your
mind at any point you're allowed to say
after the first date i don't want to see
the guy we're not here to think oh you
just wanted a free meal out of me you
[ __ ] cheap no sometimes you're just
not into the guy that you meet in person
i've had girls going one day with me and
say i don't want to see you again it
happens
it's okay
but you can't always this is the bad
blood that exists in politics that
exists in dating it's not this is that
people
will never think that you're coming at
things with good intentions oh yeah all
the guys that go on dates with their
[ __ ] and narcissist all my exes or
pieces of [ __ ] the reason why
you remember something differently than
me is you're trying to gaslight me or
maybe two people can witness the same
thing and remember it completely
different because memory is foggy people
always assume
that you got [ __ ] up intentions if
they're feeling a [ __ ] up emotion yes
right i'm hurt therefore you and i
wanted to hurt me yeah they never just
say
things didn't work out
all right so
i'm not saying that there aren't people
who do manipulation i'm not saying there
aren't people who do that kind of
misleading stuff
but
if he would have been honest with me
from the get-go
i would have been like sure
and now i'm crying over this man that i
didn't even really like like he's a
mediocre white man like the rest of them
and here i am crying about him but it's
not even about wait wait wait and if you
guys like today's video make sure you
put it with like a little comment it
helps us out that youtube algorithm wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute this right there
makes me think of
yo you cute and everything and stuff yo
you just a [ __ ] anyways that's what i
like after you get rejected you know
when guys act like that they can't call
you and then you say no and then they
like
remember remember
that's made that made me thinks about
that like once you got rejected now he's
just a like basic ass [ __ ] he's
a mediocre white man yeah but that's
what you wanted you slept so so it says
more about you than the man because you
slept with a mediocre white man and i
promise you go to the comments of this
thing and they'll be like girl i get you
i understand yeah probably a woman can
just get up here and talk [ __ ] about men
like this yes
mediocre white man
you imagine if i stopped seeing a girl
and i was like man see that's the
problem with women she was just a
mediocre black woman
y'all would lose your [ __ ] minds
you would lose your [ __ ] minds don't
even cap you're on your own don't even
don't even camp yo you would lose your
mind
i'm not doing it and this is a toxicity
of women that gets to be online without
anybody calling them out on the [ __ ]
and not only do they get to do it it's
yas coin
go girl tell him the truth
[ __ ] zaddy
what did you say [ __ ] zaddy [ __ ] i don't
know ain't that what the kids say
hey that was the k how old i'm the old
one not you [ __ ] i don't know what
happened bro this pandemic hates me like
ten years but
i'll be looking outside my curtain like
yeah my get off my lawn you ain't got no
lawn yeah i know i know i don't know i
don't know
i'd be looking out like [ __ ] kids
the color people
it's not even about him it's about the
disrespect
it's about your ego a boo-boo
take a few seats take several seats okay
you have a over-inflated sense of
self-worth one two you haven't been
checked by life enough to humble
yourself but i can i can you know she
said she had a gut syndrome yeah then
she was what she said the god complex
the guy completely i don't think she did
that where the fart the first one she
said i know i'm working with all this
look at me honey what the [ __ ]
this is for all my girlies who like me
have a god complex and an inferiority
complex
a god complex and an inferiority complex
she started the [ __ ] video with that
[ __ ]
so
i'm mad yeah i wasn't trying to gaslight
you into thinking that didn't happen we
and you couldn't even do me the favor
of just being up front with me
instead i have to sit here and think
that oh maybe someone actually
values me for more than just my body you
know
i'm sorry i don't care what it is once a
woman starts crying i start chuckling
yeah you can miss me with them tears
okay y'all gotta learn to handle your
l's more gracefully because that's not
even that big of an l1 and two okay how
you gonna [ __ ] on this man tell you oh
you know he's average mediocre white man
i didn't like it that much
why would somebody value it like yo
chill okay get off your high horse ego
get off your high horse i've taken way
bigger else than that and never thought
of talking about women the same way you
did this i was in the bushes and i was
still like she's a pretty cool girl geez
abba do you have more stories like that
no got enough stories like that bro
please tell us
i'ma just tell you this you know what
for therapy i used to sit in a dark room
and play
[ __ ] i used to play in a dark room
when when i was heartbroken i used to
play brian mcknight do i ever cross your
mind
anytime
do you ever wake up reaching out for me
hmm yeah
brian mcknight yeah sorry yeah mr white
knight yeah that was me yeah yeah in the
darkness
you want to talk about [ __ ] behavior
[ __ ] i did that [ __ ] but never thought
that whole time i was like these [ __ ]
mediocre losers huh cause i didn't even
like i just took my l and i cried you
went and you ruined your little dark
space yes only me and brian mcknight no
but you know what they say what being
vulnerable is the new sexy
[ __ ] bro
but all this to say
you gotta look at yourself and find out
why you take a rejection so terribly one
and two why you so comfortable
broadcasting into the world and not
recognizing your own dysfunction in that
moment it's like you even posted that
[ __ ] online looking weird so uh that's
just my thoughts on it but
yeah you lost all sympathy for me once
you start talking [ __ ] about people like
that that's crazy and ladies you gotta
also admit if a man did that [ __ ] y'all
would never let that [ __ ] fly
never
mediocre black woman that's crazy talk
i'd never think of saying some [ __ ]
i i've had you know mediocre people
reject me and you know what it's okay
that's okay i took that out yeah
she's so [ __ ] average i didn't want
her no
i wanted you in that moment you were
trying to get with that guy you are the
one who's so butthurt about it if he's
that mediocre what does that [ __ ]
make you
mediocre
below mediocre because he's not bothered
by it he's not bothered by you
whatsoever he already moved on you're
the one who's butt hurt
get your [ __ ] together yo but anyways
that's just my thoughts what do you
think
like i said eric shut the [ __ ] up this
ain't john lane this ain't my lane but
you said what you said and i understand
exactly what the [ __ ] you mean like
i see what you're saying i see and the
switch up is really weird it's not
because yeah you said that you really
said that
but let us know what you guys think in
the comments below do you agree disagree
want to hear from you guys
and yeah that's not my name i had to let
you go that's not my line